[Music]
you
look at this girl's face like the stone
indian which that's your girl bro
oh i like that i like that
you feel that you know what he said he
said look at her and look at me
that was a compliment to you or to her
oh
i thought it was to you [ __ ] i thought
you was kind of good-looking
so that was kind of like over here
but you meant you so but we all thought
you meant that
so basically he was saying that she's
too pretty
[Applause]
they got that misconstrued because they
couldn't believe somebody could be that
much of a lying ass
liar
see what happens when you lie down it's
just whatever is she just a friend of
yours
so how long you been trying to how long
you've been trying
how long you been trying to have sex
with her and friendship your way
into it it ain't gonna happen she's
gonna use you
until you're finished she's gonna tell
you all kind of
her problems she's going to have you go
out to dinner with her
hair annie up man have her annie up man
give it up how long you been knowing him
uh uh not having a good time how long
you been knowing this guy
because i don't like her i don't even
know i don't like her already she's just
sitting there hey she's not
fun and you've been trying to make this
unfun [ __ ]
one day lay down and give you some booty
by what how how how
hey
so we're gonna start with i really miss
sarge uh i
i really hate to see it go man i really
was happy watching chinese people
walking around
uh not trying to cough you know you know
but i just love watching chinese people
get the pressure applied looking at them
like waiting for them to cough you know
you when you was working with him he was
just looking around
if you cough
this chinese dude coughs it was just
fantastic because every other disease
they blame on black people i can't get
enough of it
i'm watching uh tv monkey parks and
it was doing some magical disease white
people breaking out with this was
all and uh and so i'm looking and
they're doing the report and they show a
composite sketch of some
rat uh from africa which
which means he's black and they drew it
first of all i'm like what's this how do
you know the difference between some uh
black rat and some rat from the bronx
that's
the puerto rican hat so they they might
as well drew
a hat backwards and so
so this is the monkey park culprit watch
out for the watch out for the dirty
black rat and then uh uh
it attacked it attacked uh now white
people don't really have an animal
representative
of themselves but if he was to think of
a few
one would be a bald eagle and the other
would be a prairie dog and that's what
it attacked so it was almost just like a
newscast be on the lookout for something
right uh he he
uh bit uh some poor defenseless uh
prairie dog just watching the game and
stole his wallet and bent him in the
shoulder and gave him
i'm watching uh this bug show with the
locusts man
you know black locust from africa black
whoa watch out for black
locust africanized that's what they call
africanized big black locust rust watch
out cause they
they eat up all the crops and they don't
tip and
watch out watch out for the locusts
and y'all know about the monkey monkey
got charged up with all kind of the
monkey a's or ebola
i'm not even really scared of a's
anymore i mean cause how can you with
magic you see magic johnson he looks
fantastic
i can't be afraid he looks wonderful
he's had aids for 15 years
what kind of age he got the good guy i
want
he's been he's been opening movie
theaters
and starbucks for the last 15 years i
want that kind of age give me that
make me a better entrepreneur i need
that
patrice you got aids good i want to open
a trucking company because
this crowd is tough man you know chinese
people didn't
laugh after that but the black people in
the chinese people wrote they all was
laughing at the thing right but
that's young girls for you boy young
girls do that y'all the only thing good
about young girls y'all young girls you
know y'all young y'all look delicious
you know other than that
and they getting bigger too man these
young brothers man damn you see him
what i think of stuff they put in the
chicken and all that stuff all that
that that you know what i mean they
walking around big i saw this woman
walking down the street i was like
damn you fine how old are you she was
like four
you got some nice titties before
like i can't spell if i had to spell
restaurant
to this day right to save my mama's life
like if
like if somebody held my mom a hostage
she had a gun to her head
it says [ __ ] spell restaurant
shoot your mother in the head i'll be
like i would look at my mother like
uh i love you
you gotta look at me mom she's crying
[Applause]
understand that i i love you with all my
heart
stop stalling [ __ ] okay all right all
right
all right
all right all right all right all right
rst
oh my god here's where it gets
oh jesus christ uh
[Applause]
it's an a or you or you
all right give me a no give me another
word man give me another word one more
word
just give my mother a chance to live
tomorrow
probably god banana all right banana
banana b-a-n
a-n-n-n is it anything like seven ends
in banana
yeah and then
a-a-a
[Applause]
all right how many guys in here honestly
have used a dental dam before
[Applause]
do you know what a dental dam is you do
no one's ever used one before huh
see see what i'm saying you see what i'm
saying about the condoms y'all just like
put that condom on
but you know the dental dam is it's a
piece of a trash bag right
about as big as a napkin that you flip
out and you lay it over a woman's vagina
just in case you know it's it's it's
poison
to protect us from imminent danger
but we don't use it because you'll be
insulted
if i'm getting ready to have sex with
you and i'll pull out a piece of a trash
man
and you go uh what is that oh i'm just
gonna lay that over your vagina
just in case it kills me i'm sorry what
did you say and we see that
face like nothing forget it don't even
pretend i didn't see that i'd rather die
than to insult my way out of some i'd
rather just get what you got
how many people getting sick of the
hindu obstacle course at the
airport it's just it is
i mean i'm a racist but it's it's
it's getting
and i don't mind foreigners but don't be
from your
cup like from your country like
it's okay to be originally from there
like your parents and grandpa but you
can't be
from india and even that would
for my even
id you go what the f i know i'm american
i gotta be more american than you
because i don't go able double
that boarding pass
man i know my voice proves i'm american
like i need another
i need an american voice to ask me for
my
[ __ ] but you can't get rid of the double
day dudes cause
they're amazing like who else will work
at a 24-hour brooklyn gas station with
no bulletproof
vest and no gun
and curse [ __ ] out if they don't have
less than a 50.
double double
you need something smaller please little
vip double
pupil do that
you can't get rid of them because they
do jobs nobody else is going to do
that's why you can't really listen
what is this thing where we trying to
get mexicans out this country who else
is going to work without
mexicans and who else is going to work
who else would drive
a bicycle
on the highway who else a rider who else
would ride away man
who else would ride a bicycle on the
highway
against traffic to deliver you
a panini sandwich for lunch
on time who else
who else is gonna uh kick in your hotel
door to make your bed
beside some little mexican woman who has
an ethic she has to make your bed
i have to i have i have to make
her look and she knocks that she [ __ ]
punches the door
and she scares the [ __ ] out she kicks
the [ __ ] door and the chain is on
hello
hello and you're like miss the chain is
i'm alive the chain's on the door
you don't have ma'am please look please
i must make your bed i must
make your bed i must make your bed
please please please
you pull out a [ __ ] ikea smile [ __ ]
please and she's trying to squeeze in
through the space
through the chain space like hello
hello i must make you hello
i wish i never traveled forever real
cause i i could i would like
just never had travel outside this
country and then i could hate america
and be happy you know what i'm saying
but i traveled
and now it's like now i like america but
i still hate it's weird i hate it but
it's it's nowhere better because all i
got to really deal with is racist
crackers like that and that's
that's it's funny because like i don't
black people really don't look at white
people with like you're the oppressor
anymore it's just something we do it's
just like we like not liking white
people
and white people like not liking us it's
like it's just that's just what we do
it's just
because i'm not going nowhere and i'll
kill a [ __ ] tell me to go
like back to africa listen i'm talking
to black people stop
that [ __ ] horseshit that go
back to africa [ __ ] first of all
africans
don't like black people that's first
part
they don't like us and what the [ __ ]
am i gonna do in africa
besides fighting some war wearing uh
sweatpants and tuxedo shoes
with a [ __ ]
[Applause]
with a [ __ ] machete in my hand with a
pair of [ __ ] tuxedo shoes
and a knife fighting some goofy ass
[ __ ] wall [ __ ] it
you just gotta be honest with yourself
like okay i believe in god
all right but i don't have a religion
that's cause i'm a coward and that's
that's why i have a religion now i
believe in god but i'm just saying
my thing is i don't mind going to hell
if i'm being a sinner
and i got to go to hell my thing is i'm
afraid of going to hell for being like a
devout
wrong [ __ ] like i
i don't be praying to the wrong god
where i could have been having sex with
hookers or shooting people
only time i get really religious look at
this guy
only time i get really religious
i become a christian when i get on
airplanes that's when i get like you
know
i don't want to play in the crash so i'm
helping old ladies with their bags miss
miss no don't no no let me get that back
home
let me get that put that up there for
you look god i'm helping this old [ __ ]
up with a badge
i don't even know her you ain't you
ain't gonna let the plane crash
are you
and and i'm full of [ __ ] because when
the woman goes thank you so much for
putting my bag up and i'm like look this
this got nothing to do with you
i'm just trying to keep the plane from
crashing because cause when the plane
lands and she's looking at me like you
want to get my bag
no no no i did my job the plane's on the
ground
you think he wants to see you every day
this face
just look at her face it's just
like a stroke victim just
it's just can you imagine if i'm your
man
and i have to be with like i'm trying to
disco dance
to make your life better i'm sorry say
that again
you have to make me laugh no no
don't even go home that's what i knew
she was gonna say
that's the face she has and master
that's what you'll
deal with that's what she has to add
yeah the way you laugh who's gonna make
your miserableness
that's not my job to pull your misery
from inside your gut i don't know what
happened to you
i can't make the things you're still
dealing with from when you were six
come out and laughter
she and this is why you know she's not
this is women you have movies in your
head
that only star you directed by you
everybody else is laughing and she goes
you have to make me laugh
the fact that laughter is contagious
should help you
dead on the inside that's you
[Applause]
stop it stop it you don't know what
you're talking about
she does look at that face she knows
don't get mad i'm just saying you need
to stop being so wrapped up but that's
like he's saying you're auditioning
for him to be your man at some point
this guy is a nice guy
he actually
you know how fast i would get rid of her
as a friend
i would throw something in the garbage
just so i can blame her for stealing it
i'll be like
hey [ __ ] my watch was right here
i put it right here [ __ ]
[Applause]
you stole from me ho cuz i could never
talk to
her again
don't go too far ahead of me you ever
try to watch the special olympics
and and try not to be uncomfortable
because it's the it's the right thing to
do
and you're sitting there trying to watch
and just
and you're not an [ __ ] but the 10
meter stumble it it's
it's impossible to watch you try to you
do because you're a good person
and you march it said go
[Laughter]
oh my god they fell
and he didn't fall but what's this guy
doing one day he didn't fall but
he didn't run because the starters
pistol scared him to death so he's just
standing there
[Laughter]
you gotta shoot at his feet to make a
move or shove him
now you gotta watch out cause the
javelin guy is running all around with a
pointy stick
and he's going to stay straight ahead
you know he's going to run all over
he's happy and he can stab you right in
your chest with that stick
and if he hit you in your chest you
can't even go
try again
thank you all right
eight inches
i hate how much fun black people can
have racially man it's just
i can say anything i goddamn want
racially and why people have to sit
there and take it
oh yeah i'm evil yeah he's like come on
man
i i don't even say it because of that i
like i i love i love a little ratio yes
look man you know let's be fair i mean
honestly be nicer with the racial game i
mean it it
i like to talk to uh you know white
people about being honest about uh
obama you gave it a shot you did
you gave it a two-year shot like oh yeah
i tried i tried to
we tried to but you see not
it's not it's just it fell apart it
really
it really did and i'm gonna tell you
something you don't know about black
folks
we would be on your side uh
and talking to white people we would be
on your side a lot more if you would uh
you know just not ever talk about how
you
feel about anything
racial we'll catch up to you not serious
because black people on the edge of
going what the [ __ ] is obama doing
but it's too many white people outwardly
hating them so we can't we go if you
shut the [ __ ]
you shut up i'll be against them like
stop i'm loving rallies and all kinds of
stuff i'm telling you i'm this close to
i'm mad at him because i thought i would
have a white slave but i thought
i thought it was vengeance day
[Applause]
gonna have me a white family oh big old
fat white girl go warm up better
get upstairs susan
warm my bed up feed my baby with your
giant white titties and
i'm gonna go outside and stare your
husband in the face and decide whether
i'm gonna sell them or not
now you know your wife's upstairs
warming up my bed you know that right
fill up
[Applause]
that's uncomfortable in it that's
something that's uncomfortable i
apologize
i never thought mike tyson and the
reason i'm saying this because
[ __ ] now he's fighting like
farmers they got mike fighting
anybody just to say mike we want to see
you knock a [ __ ]
out again he was so special as a
knockout artist we hated to see him when
he got on the rape beef
that i never believe especially based on
the last interview we had with
greta van suskin and he goes
she goes what do you have to say to your
victims mike he goes well
i wish i had to really rape the [ __ ]
and her mama i wish i had to really rape
the [ __ ] and a mama i'm like oh
that is an innocent man that's the
i'm telling you only an innocent man
could be that angry and say some [ __ ]
that [ __ ] up
like i i wish i had a rape decide to be
in jail for something instead of raping
the [ __ ] and i really didn't
so that's mike's way of like figuring it
all out
and her testimony years ago which cut me
off
even without the interview but interview
solidified it
her testimony he forced oral sex on me
and i said damn he made you suck his
dick that's terrible
he ate a [ __ ] that's when it was like
case
case dismissed cause what rapist tries
to make you feel wonderful i
i've been eating [ __ ] in a long time
and i never eat it rapey how the [ __ ] do
you think shout out [ __ ] shut up
shut up my ninja [ __ ] shut up
wow peel away the outer lips and
slide the hood back to expose your
clitoris
for maximum stimulation shut the [ __ ] up
you can't even make a mean face while
you eat [ __ ] you can't you be like
shut up
you better not be enjoying this [ __ ]
[Applause]
has any woman in here be getting a [ __ ]
eating been going hell
police
owe me my [ __ ] somebody do something
shut up nobody hear your cries
[Applause]
we're like uh i'm trying to
like make it so women just like
understand a little bit of like just to
sympathize it's like we're like sport
fishermen that's what i'm saying
men like to fish and sport fishing is
different from catching
fish for food you just get it you get it
you catch it
and you you know you you show your
friends
because you want them to know that you
you can catch fish
you take a couple of pictures so you can
show people to fish
that you have the ability to catch
and then you release it back into the
water
but a lot of women in here you have
boyfriends or husbands
you were fish that jumped back on the
boat
and just was like flapping looking at me
like
hi i was wondering if you're going to be
fishing here again next week like
yeah for other fish get off my boat
is that how you treat all the fish you
be like oh
god damn nope i'm sorry sweetie you the
last fish i ever wanted to be with now
you stuck
stuck with the last fish who was loving
you and fighting hard to be on your boat
then she got comfortable and now instead
of doing this she's like so
we've been together for like
a year now why do you still have a boat
you'd be like
so what's he trying to say i can't catch
fish no more
because if i lose my ability to catch
fish then you're not gonna find me sexy
no more so you gotta smell
fish on me so that you know i can catch
fish so you can act right
that's like guys you meet your girl she
was a hoe
like had whole like she big old booty
and this and that
you got to let her do that don't start
trying to trump her up and get a fat and
get a foul
because that's why you like her i don't
want no woman that
no other guy is trying to i don't want a
woman
that i can send to the store at two in
the morning
cause nobody's gonna try to rape her
like i go
go get some bread at three in the
morning hey cut through the alley [ __ ]
cause
cause i talked to the junkies they don't
want it they ain't got they don't like
you
[Applause]
like ladies let's discuss even look
let's discuss
harassment for a second
let's just see you feel it a little bit
like let's just discuss it
why can't i
harass you
[Applause]
sometimes sometimes
[Applause]
i can never harass you never
and i'm not talking about
[Applause]
like i'm talking just
at the job it's unfair
that i can't harass you at the workplace
like
you look at how you looking and i can't
just
a little something that has to do like
you got to be careful just to say hey
you look beautiful today
that's how messed up the game is i think
you should be able to comment on any
part of the body
that you see if you
i'm serious what's your name
what's your name genie now genie no
disrespect but if i work with you
i should be able to walk in and go oh
genie beautiful
uh titty meat you have there
and because i see that
but whatever the scientific term is i'm
looking at mr
a 4.9 grade point average what's the
what's the science term for uh the titty
meat what's the actual
and it's not the cleavage i mean the
cleavage is the space in the middle i'm
talking about the meat
the meat the titty part
and i'm not being fouled just you know
whoa
you know what i'm saying just so i can
go through the rest
of the day without pretending
that i don't see which which you
understand what i'm saying
i mean let's work out a deal don't get
me fired
having women work with men right is like
having a grizzly bear work with salmon
[Applause]
dipped in honey like so now you dip the
salmon in the honey right grizzly bears
and the salmon get to walk through
comfortable with honey
and fish and good morning grizzly bears
and the grizzly bears is like hey
he can't even he didn't even growl like
ah what's up fish
oh my god human resources the grizzly
bear just did grizzly bears
so so
[Applause]
like i can't even go hey good morning
good morning fish good morning
oh i can't touch you like oh look at
that
oh let me just get a little bit of that
fish a little bit
get that honey oh my god
fish and honey man that's my favorite
usually i kill fish
and eat them and stuff but i just wanted
to just rub that
rub a little bit
god damn
[Applause]
that's oppressive like you shouldn't
even
and there's cameras everywhere you can't
do like
weird stuff behind the back like
why would it be disrespectful i said
what's your name
tyrell if i go ty tyrell we work
together and i go tyrone hey do me a
favor
let me know when you're getting up to go
to the bathroom so i can sniff your
chair
[Applause]
that's disrespectful because it's sexual
but that keeps me
from being like i think look
i think there should be a holiday uh for
lack of a better word
harassment day but not that sounds
whatever
but i mean a day where i get to
find out like because and this is why it
should be harassment day
because women get to be inappropriate
sexually all the time you get to be
inappropriate and when i say
inappropriate i mean
say hello to me too close hi
or some weird massage because you think
we're friends and you
good morning little kiss and he's just
like oh
oh boy oh boy boy boy boy
and you think in your head man i wonder
if i could i wonder
but harassment day allows you to be able
to ask
all year i say the tuesday before
[Applause]
thanksgiving
and it's and it's a beautiful day
flowers and everything you buy flowers
you're just real cool you walk up you're
respectful you say hey how are you
you know good afternoon to her happy
harassment day
and you just like say listen i was
wondering
all year if you would suck my dick in a
broom clown
[Applause]
and you just be like no thank you i'm
not and you play i'm thank you keep the
flowers i just thought
i made a mistake i thought you was a
whole all year
i was confused i thought you was a hoe
but you're not